vamos ahora con el problema 99 en el
problema 99 nos preguntan si m&m es
distinto de n me gustan estos en los que
nada más tenemos poquitos símbolos bueno
la opción 1 es decirnos que m n es menor
que cero por supuesto esto no nos va a
poder permitir concluir si m es distinto
de n o lo contrario porque por ejemplo
puede ser que me sea igual a n que sea
igual a menos uno son iguales y su xoom
es menos 2 entonces aquí son iguales o
puede ser que me sea igual a 5 que es
igual a menos 6 y su suma también es
menor que 0 mn de hecho es menos uno que
es menor que cero entonces no son
iguales y cumplen esto entonces estos
ejemplos muestran que esta información
no es suficiente para determinar si son
distintos vamos al 2 en el 2 nos dicen
que m n es menor que cero ok esto está
más interesante a ver si es mejor en es
menor que cero entonces mn tienen signos
distintos y x
tanto deben de ser diferentes verdad uno
tiene que ser positivo y el otro
negativo y entonces no pueden ser
iguales entre sí por lo tanto este
inciso si nos permite concluir que m es
distinto que n porque deben tener signos
distintos entonces aquí la respuesta
sería b muy bien ahora vamos al problema
100 en el problema 100 nos dicen lo
siguiente nos dice que en cierto juego
un jugador empezó a lanzar una moneda
cierta cantidad de veces y cuando lo
hizo resulta que hubo cuatro águilas más
que lo que hubo de soles entonces cuatro
águilas más de lo que hubo de soles la
cantidad de águilas fue igual a la
cantidad de soles más cuatro
muy bien y además nos dice que siempre
salió águila o sol
entonces siempre salió águila o sol y la
pregunta es cuántas águilas salieron
vale entonces vamos nos preguntan por el
valor de a bueno pues vamos a ver qué
información tenemos en el inciso 1 lo
que nos dice es que el jugador lanzó la
moneda 24 veces o sea que además ese a
más ese es igual a 24 damos el brinco
porque vemos dos ecuaciones lineales en
dos variables así que podemos
resolverlas nada más le voy a poner que
esta información es suficiente ya
tenemos esta con esta y con eso podemos
determinar a y ese vale no lo voy a
hacer porque nuestra el chiste de simat
vamos al 2 en el 2 lo que nos dicen es
que el jugador recibió tres puntos por
cada águila que obtuvo y un punto por
cada sol que obtuvo y en total tuvo 52
puntos ok entonces tres veces el número
de águilas es los puntos por águilas
1 por s osea s son los puntos por soles
nos dicen que es igual a 52 52 otra vez
lo del inciso 2 con lo que tenemos aquí
arriba son dos ecuaciones en dos
variables y por lo tanto podemos
resolverlas para determinar el valor de
a y de ese entonces éste también es
suficiente por sí mismo la respuesta es
de de vamos ahora el problema 101 guau
ya llevamos 100 problemas resueltos esto
está muy divertido vamos a seguirle a
ver hasta dónde llegamos entonces
problemas 101 nos dice ese es una
secuencia infinita wow en donde ese 1 es
igual a 9 s 2 es igual a 99
s 3 es igual a 999 ok creo que ya le
caché pero mira aquí nos aclaran s k es
igual a 10 a la k menos 1 si funciona
verdad si k es igual a 3 tenemos mil
menos uno que es 999 va y lo que nos
preguntan es si todo término de ese todo
terminó
término de ese será divisible por
divisible por el primo p
el primo primo
ok pues creo que podemos simplificar
esta pregunta o sea si todo término de
ese es divisible por p entonces el
primero es divisible por p vale pero si
un primo p divide a es al primero como 9
divide a todos entonces tendríamos que
ese primo dividiría a todos entonces
básicamente esta pregunta la podemos
cambiar así p divide a 9 vale bueno como
opciones en la 1 nos dicen que p es
mayor que 2 esto no es suficiente verdad
que puede ser 3 y puede dividir a 9 o
que puede ser 7 y pueden no dividir a 9
entonces ésta por sí misma no es
suficiente vamos al 2 lo que nos dice el
2 es que al menos
al menos un término de ese término de s
es divisible es divisible
/ p / p a ver si esto es suficiente pues
no verdad por ejemplo puede ser que el
primo sea sea 3 y que en efecto divida a
todos o sea que 3 divida 9 y en efecto 3
divide a todos pero pero no sé o sea
puede ser que el primo sea 11 porque 11
divide a 99 pero 11 no divide a 9
entonces esta información por sí misma
no es suficiente y juntándolas tampoco
tenemos nada porque otra vez el primo
puede ser 11 11 es mayor que 2 y no
divide a todos o el primo puede ser 33
divide a todos verdad divide alguno y es
mayor que 2 entonces ni siquiera
juntándolas la respuesta sería
y ahora vamos al 102 en el problema 102
tenemos un dibujo que voy a hacer aquí
es un trapecio entonces tenemos este
lado un lado paralelo
esta unidad con esta esta unidad con
esta además nos marcan esta de acá que
baja perpendicularmente y tenemos
algunos nombres y algunas longitudes que
es r
ese té
a esta altura es de 60 metros esta
pequeña longitud es de 15 metros y esta
longitud de arriba es de 45 metros
déjame ver si es todo lo que tenemos si
me parece que si va entonces nos dice
aquí
que el cuadrilátero rst y que se muestra
aquí arriba es un plano en el cual eeuu
es paralelo a este y rv es más largo que
éste y con el cual se va a ser un
estacionamiento ok y la que lo que nos
preguntan es cuál es el área lo que
necesitamos determinar es el área
bueno vamos a pensar le tantito en
realidad ya tenemos el área de este
triángulo de acá o bueno podemos
determinar la verdad conocemos la base y
la altura aquí también pues podemos
trazar esta altura de acá y aquí se nos
forma un rectángulo donde también
podemos determinar el área ya conocemos
que que éste es de 45 entonces este es
de 45 y este de acá es de 60
porque estas son paralelas entonces es
bueno es un rectángulo porque son
paralelas entonces tienen estas
longitudes de modo que podemos conocer
esta área y conocemos esta altura así
que básicamente todos se reducen
encontrar el área total se reduce a
poder determinar este valor x de acá
vale bueno vamos a ver que nos dan como
opciones en el inciso 1 nos dicen que
erre 1
rv es igual a 80 metros metros
eso me parece suficientemente bueno
tenemos que eeuu es igual a 80 metros
entonces pues rv o sea entonces x es lo
que sobra de a hereu quitarle de r hasta
aquí y eso si lo conocemos eso es 60
vale entonces tenemos que x es igual a
80 menos 60 que es igual a 20 20 metros
y con x igual a 20 ya podemos hacer todo
verdad no vamos a determinar el área
simplemente nos interesa que podemos
encontrarla ya conociendo x podemos
conocer el área de aquí y con eso
conocer el área de todo el trapecio vale
bueno entonces este si funciona por sí
mismo y el inciso 2 lo que nos dicen es
que tf1
es igual a 20 por raíz de 10 20 por raíz
de 10 10 no de 0 metros
entonces nos dan la longitud de este de
acá lo voy a poner con otro color 20
raíz de 10 metros bueno pues esto
también va a ser suficiente porque
tenemos que este ángulo de acá es recto
de modo que t
y este punto de acá digamos w es un
triángulo rectángulo y entonces podemos
aplicar el teorema de pitágoras para
determinar este valor de x tenemos que
60 al cuadrado más x al cuadrado es
igual a 20 raíz de 10 al cuadrado de
modo que 3600 más x al cuadrado es igual
a cuánto nos da aquí a ver nos da 20 al
cuadrados 400 raíz de 10 al cuadrado es
10 entonces nos queda 4000
y de aquí podemos obtener que x al
cuadrado es 4000 menos 3.600 o sea 400
de modo que x una vez más es igual a 20
vale entonces tenemos la longitud de x
que es igual a 20 esta de acá y como
dije eso ya nos permite encontrar el
área como platicamos al inicio va bueno
entonces la respuesta es que este
también funciona y así tenemos que la
respuesta es de cualquier inciso por sí
mismo nos permite responder la pregunta